muy bien
hola que tal un cordial saludo a todas y
todos y bienvenidos a este castor
cibernético o canadá en las américas
café que excepcionalmente estamos
transmitiendo hoy a las 1130 que desde
desde un lugar en que ustedes ya verán
que no es el estudio de radio canadá
internacional
este programa es en directo por facebook
live youtube y nuestro sitio internet
rc y net juntos ya leonora en bienvenida
igualmente y bienvenido a todos es
nuestros nuestras invitadas es una
casualidad son todas mujeres estamos
aquí en el salón de la inmigración y de
la integración y este es justamente el
lugar donde uno puede encontrar
respuestas a todas las preguntas que se
hace sobre inmigración sobre integración
es un salón que se lleva a cabo una vez
por año dura dos días hay 10.000
personas que visitan este lugar en estos
dos días y las
nos dice a dónde voy a la ciudad a la
región a dónde me voy a alojar si soy
estudiante si soy trabajador temporal
todas las respuestas están aquí en este
salón de la inmigración y de la
integración en montreal temas que sin
duda ya hemos abordado a lo largo de
todos los programas nuestros en radio
canadá internacional pero hoy tenemos la
oportunidad de encontrarnos aquí en el
salón de la inmigración en el palacio de
congresos de montreal y contentos de
haber salido del estudio lord y por fin
salimos de cuatro paredes chiquitas es
inmenso este lugar yo no sé si las
cámaras de leonardo están apuntando para
allá porque se podría ver hay una
cantidad impresionante de gente hay más
de un centenar de expertos que están en
este lugar participando para responder a
las preguntas justamente que se hace la
gente y pues creo que es muy interesante
de que nuestros oyentes en américa
latina cuántas veces pablo nos hacen
preguntas que nosotros no somos expertos
en inmigración que hoy pueden escuchar
las respuestas
bueno vamos a ver cómo vamos a funcionar
con la tecnología que nos está
arrollando definitivamente bueno pero
tratamos de hacer lo mejor posible un
caluroso saludo a todos ustedes allá los
que están en este momento aquí en el
salón y están observando viendo este
programa y los que están allá del otro
lado de la cámara en cualquier lugar del
mundo donde se encuentren bienvenidos a
este castor cibernético que bueno pues
es un programa muy especial estamos acá
tenemos invitadas y creo que leonora
vamos a pedirle a nuestras invitadas que
se presenten en el master que nos digan
bueno el nombre del lugar de donde de
origen de que en qué país nacieron y
pues a qué organismos representan
entonces empezamos podemos empezar aquí
con maría bueno mi nombre es maría mejía
yo soy consejera de empleo para el
organismo lounge creen zhanjiang
richelieu y vengo de colombia muy bien
entonces seguimos con adriana hola
buenos días gracias por la invitación y
un saludo a toda la audiencia en mi
nombre es adriana
yo trabajo para al para un organismo que
ayuda a los inmigrantes aquí en montreal
nadie nadie amar estoy de origen
argelino vivo aquí en canadá desde casi
20 años trabajo un bufete de abogados y
en materia de inmigración y llevo
prácticamente 12 15 años de experiencia
en materia legal en inmigración muy bien
cecilia cecilia escambia soy salvadoreña
y trabajo en casa soy la directora de
café del centro de ayuda a familias
latinoamericanas
claudia hola muy buenos días mi nombre
es claudia mancilla yo soy de origen
chilena trabajo para el organismo fueron
2020 en la ciudad de santiago
sara hola que tal mi nombre es sarah
tapia un placer estar esta mañana con
ustedes yo nací en méxico y trabajo para
que vea internacional que es la agencia
de desarrollo económico de la gran
región metropolitana de quebec pues muy
diversificado pablo invitadas son todas
mujeres fue fue adrede no no van a ganar
yo soy honesto y solo digo que no lo
hice adrede es una coincidencia y bueno
y estoy muy satisfecho y muy contento de
esa coincidencia pues aquí vamos a
empezar con nadie
madre nadie trabaja en un nuevo fete de
abogados o casualidad son nueve abogadas
todas mujeres es que fue casualidad o
fue adrede también adrede absolutamente
adrede fue lo que él decidió al ustedes
que van a ser mujeres capella llegaron
todas nueve mujeres abogadas nadie hay
muchísimas preguntas que me gustaría
hacerte pero no va a haber mucho tiempo
que ustedes trabajan dan servicios por
ejemplo a estudiantes extranjeros que
vienen a canadá y que quieren quedarse
en el país como hace un estudiante
extranjero que viene de chile de mexico
de argentina y dice yo vengo a estudiar
pero finalmente me gusta este lugar me
gusta que ve que me voy a quedar claro
la misión es nuestro bufete es acompañar
a todos los demandantes que vienen a
canadá en forma temporal y también
permanente
explicarles y llevarles a llevar todos
los procedimientos legales jurídicos en
materia de materia de pidió la
residencia permanente como se sabe el
proceso migratorio canadiense es un poco
complicado es muy diversificado por lo
cual existe un derecho de inmigración
como tal existe un ministerio por lo
cual eso indica que hay todo un proceso
complejo en a veces para poder llevar a
cabo todos los índices legales para
lograr tiene la residencia permanente y
hay varios programas por supuesto y
también depende de cada provincia donde
pueden llegar muchísima gente de todas
partes del mundo entre los programas que
llevan a la residencia permanente entre
ellos hay el programa de los estudiantes
extranjeros que actualmente el gobierno
de canadá desde hace como 89 años está
dando mucha importancia a este programa
para poder mantener a una masa demasiada
grande que llega anualmente que hace
alrededor de 200 mil personas
que estamos hablando de estudiantes
extranjeros 1000 estudiantes que llega a
estudiar a canadá anualmente que es una
materia bastante calificada que habla 23
idiomas formados en canadá en grandes
colegios universidades que esta gente
hace algunos años para atrás el gobierno
o sea el sistema migratorio canadiense
no había creado un una una forma de
mantener después de terminar el curso
que la gente no se fueran entonces ahora
dieron todo a bases se contabiliza por
ejemplo si un estudiante está a 4 años
para hacer un vacuna una licenciatura
esos 4 años si él decide quedarse valen
como antecedente para la inmigración
ahora contabiliza absolutamente ahora no
solamente cuatro años de tres inclusive
un año hay programas hasta una persona
llega a estudiar un año termina ese
califica a emigrar por ejemplo en la
provincia de québec dado que habla a los
idiomas dado gratuitamente que ya está
integrado a la sociedad exactamente por
lo cual inmigración que nada se dice
percato hacia algunos años para atrás
y esa gran masa popular que viene a
estudiar en canadá que está preparada
dentro del sistema educativo local la
posibilidad de integrarse más rápido
bueno a mí me gustaría encadenar
justamente ya que nadie está hablando de
estudiantes internacionales con sara
tapia que ella pues como lo decía
anteriormente es consejera para la
clientela en estudiantes internacionales
en quebec e internacional como es la
como el cual es el servicio en
particular que quebec e internacional
ofrece de sara a los estudiantes pero
que si primero que todo me gustaría
mencionar que yo llegué a quebec como
estudiante internacional y va muy bien
esta es una experiencia personal
exactamente
entonces dice el pasaje hacia la
residencia permanente y de hecho le
estoy esperando en este momento y el
mandato que ve que internacional viene
de la parte del ministerio de
inmigración de la diversidad de ligre de
acá entonces recibimos este mandato para
apoyar a los estudiantes internacionales
que están en la región metropolitana de
quebec para que puedan quedarse después
de los estudios qué es lo que hacemos
concretamente
nos apoyamos en lo que refiere al
proceso de inmigración organizamos
sesiones informativas para que ellos
estén conscientes de cuáles son los
pasos a seguir para llegar a la
residencia permanente y esto lo hacemos
con el ministerio enseguida ese otro
aspecto fundamental el empleo que es
cualquier preocupación de cualquier
persona que termina los estudios es
encontrar un trabajo entonces nosotros
lo que hacemos es ponerlos en contacto
con empleadores potenciales informarlos
sobre el mercado de trabajo en nuestra
región y de las oportunidades excelentes
que existen para ellos una vez que
deciden quedarse y establecer una vida
profesional y personal en nuestra región
tenemos un programa por ejemplo que se
llama 10 por 10 que se trata de realizar
visitas en empresas para 10 estudiantes
y son 10 empresas que participan les
permite tener una experiencia concreta y
desarrollar su desarrollo perdón su red
profesional que es básica para poder
encontrar un trabajo y se dirige los
servicios que ustedes ofrecen a
estudiantes internacionales
solo latinoamericano pero de cualquier
parte del de todo el mundo
yo tendría una pregunta para nadie
conectada con estudiantes
brevemente nadie es que en cualquier
estudiante todos los estudiantes tienen
derecho a pedir la inmigración o hay una
selección según los estudios que estén
haciendo absolutamente claro el mercado
laboral ingresa en función en función de
la ciudad
absolutamente y hay un sistema de
puntuación que se hace no pero hay
también programas que están directamente
aceptados en el programa del pj- que se
llama el programa de extensión esquive
cual es que permite a los estudiantes
que están graduados en page de omán y
maestría directamente o un valor o on
dec profesional que hasta un 10 y pide
1800 horas calificarse automáticamente a
obtener la selección a un mes de
terminar el curso perfecto bien como ya
sabemos pues muchas veces en el proceso
de inmigración los inmigrantes
cogen los grandes centros metropolitanos
para establecerse pero bueno ahora ya
estoy estamos viendo que hay organismos
que se han creado fuera de los grandes
centros metropolitanos y justamente con
maría mejía me gustaría que nos hablara
un poco de este organismo blanquer en
francés que podríamos traducir al
español como el ancla entonces qué pasa
con el ancla con ustedes trabajan en una
región que es el alto richelieu
el servicio land cree acompaña las
personas inmigrantes que quieren
establecerse en saiáns richelieu desde
el año 2007
hacemos un acompañamiento en la búsqueda
de empleo orientación profesional y la
acogida a la instalación de todas las
personas que quieran instalarse en
nuestra región
sun yang xu richelieu pues es una ciudad
que queda es la ciudad principal de la
municipalidad de los repelió una
municipalidad que conecta a los eeuu con
la parte sub de montreal es una ciudad
cercada tiene cerca de 110 mil
habitantes tiene todos los servicios
atrás
[Música]
hemos hecho un cálculo de alrededor de
2.200 personas que se han trasladado a
la región y han hecho calado y son
cuando decimos dos mil y pico de
personas son tan familias son
contabilidad son individuos vivos y
vivos o que vienen de orígenes diversos
anti están en una ciudad muy francófona
a la base entonces la nacionalidad de
las personas que llegan allá son
diferentes pero es la francofonía pura
del planeta o sea haitianos igual de
costa de marfil franceses marroquí y hay
latinoamericanos que tienen americanos
hay santi están también es considerado
una ciudad que recibe la inmigración con
refugio ok pero después del trabajo
fueron 20 20 en estos 10 años la
comunidad ha cambiado completamente
cuáles son los atractivos que tiene una
ciudad como santiago los mismos
servicios que podía decir marías mi
colegio en los todos los servicios tenga
ya se lleve hospital de hyères es el
preuniversitario el preuniversitario sí
y que el desafío mayor que tiene un
inmigrante cuando llega acá porque como
hablamos con nuestros colegas es una
transformación completa casi mismo
psicológica el momento de llegar y
atreverse a dar el salto a su misión
hará colocar su sede en distintas
regiones es llegar a tener la casa
propia y en regiones ese es un atractivo
muy fuerte y que se puede conseguir
mucho más barato es mucho más barato
yo creo que estamos hablando de un 25 30
por ciento menos de valor de una vida
así y si hablamos de la compra de
vivienda puede ser el porcentaje de
digamos menos es el sueño realizado en
la ciudad es mucho más fácil y no
necesariamente con salarios muy muy alto
solamente con un histórico bancario
estable y la persona puede acceder
obviamente con una revisión que
corresponde puede acceder a una hora
comprar una casa la primera habitación y
mencionaste también que hay refugiados
eso me lleva un poco hablar con adriana
que está trabajando en el organismo
y acogida contacto con los inmigrantes
los recién llegados y justamente tu
especialidad está centrada en ayudarle a
los inmigrantes a encontrar alojamiento
es quizás un problema serio el
alojamiento sí pues efectivamente
trabajo en 'la para un organismo que
tiene mucha experiencia para ayudar a
los inmigrantes ofrecemos nuestros
servicios en español
más bien en todos los idiomas requeridos
nuestros servicios son gratuitos
aquí en montreal y bueno sea como tú
mencionaste trabajo sobre todo yo van
dirigidos mucho a los refugiados a los
refugiados pero al para trabajar con
todos los inmigrantes en el caso mío
particular yo trabajo específicamente
con los solicitantes de asilo que
sabemos que el contexto en que ve que es
particular estamos recibiendo muchísimos
demandantes de asilo y bueno pero al
pagar realmente ayuda a todos los
inmigrantes tenemos tres principales
venas que es el la búsqueda de empleo
que es la francis acción y el
establecimiento y en ese establecimiento
realmente
también a los no nada más a los
residentes permanentes
no importa qué estatus migratorio nos
visitan todos son bienvenidos pero como
documentos si efectivamente sabemos que
hay un gran aumento de demandantes de
asilo o solicitantes de asilo y bueno
les ayudamos a su establecimiento y ha
incluso hemos agregado servicios que no
están financiados porque se cubren
algunos servicios para los demandantes
de asilo sin embargo hay servicios que
que no están financiados y alpa está
abriendo esas puertas porque porque no
queremos que estos demandantes de asilo
estos solicitantes de asilo queden
rezagados porque después en un futuro
una parte de estos demandantes de asilo
van a que van a quedarse entonces no
queremos este desfase de integración por
eso al paãs instaurado también estas
estas medidas para también ayudarlos en
la búsqueda de empleo cosas que no están
todavía también ustedes es un organismo
de integración socio también socio
profesional es angular
y como comenté tenemos esos diferentes
aspectos y empleo' francis acción e
integración y establecimiento pasado
aquí en montreal basado aquí en montreal
nuestros servicios son gratuitos y no
importa el estatus migratorio que usted
tiene usted puede venir todos los que
quieran incluso los que nos escuchan
fuera pero ya tienen la información en
toda ocasión y bueno me gustaría
conversar ahora con cecilia ivonne
escamilla ella es la directora general
de caf la centro de ayuda a familias
latinoamericanas entonces cecilia como
su nombre lo indica ustedes se dirigen a
las familias inmigrantes emigrantes de
origen hispano latinoamericanos esa fue
la misión de caf la desde un principio
ayudar a nuestras familias a integrarse
plenamente aquí en esta ciudad dentro de
poco tendremos 15 años ya de existir y
dentro de nuestra misión ha sido como te
repito cuando se cuando se fundó carla
se creó para evitar la deserción escolar
en junio fui jóvenes en el 2003
se fundó para crear para evitar la
deserción escolar de jóvenes de origen
latino que participaban en clases de
acogida de escuelas secundarias
continuamos a trabajar en eso tenemos
puntos de servicio en tres escuelas
secundarias en dos de ellas trabajamos
con los jóvenes recién llegados que son
los que forman parte de las clases de
acogida tenemos ocho clases de acogida
en la escuela albillos de pepino y 2 767
en la escuela luís riel estamos en
escuela pero márquez está en la escuela
pair market pues estamos con las clases
regulares la deserción escolar en los
jóvenes recién llegados es tiene una
estadística bien elevada y en el año en
que se creó carla pues había un 60 por
ciento de jóvenes perdón que se
abandonaba en la escuela y sabemos que
la integración no solamente lingüística
sino que en esta edad de la secundaria
donde los chicos están entre 12 y 17
años es la integración cultural line
la lingüística la de escolares con la de
los amigos entonces la integración viene
a ser de veras socialmente
pues enorme y la deserción pues se daba
mucho en esta época pues la inmigración
ha cambiado un poco y hay clases de
acogida y se sigue trabajando con esto y
se sigue y en carla pues favorecemos
mucho la integración laboral de las
familias que están recién llegadas
también me llamó la atención lo que lo
que decías con él esto no más de alfa
que de alpa de alteración sí porque
tenemos estamos con una realidad en este
momento acá en montreal donde si hay
muchas personas que solicitan asilo pero
también hay muchas personas que quedan
ya desprotegidas completamente sin
siquiera una solicitud de asilo en caf
la tenemos un servicio de su tiene
individual de apoyo individual de un
servicio de escucha que pues es algo que
lo hacemos como con puros voluntarios y
es ver de verdad para darle ese apoyo a
familias que hay veces sus hijos no han
podido ir a la escuela porque si mal no
recuerdan cuando una persona pues
quedaba casi desprotegida de leyes el
niño no podía ir a la escuela ahora ya
van a poder ir a partir de septiembre
entonces este tipo de apoyo para que
ellos se integrarán laboralmente pues
css se ha dado en el organismo si
tendría otra pregunta siguiendo en el
tema de los estudiantes nadie
ustedes también tienen trabajan con ese
programa especial que se llama pdte que
permiso vacaciones trabajo absolutamente
en qué consiste ese es ese programa
específico que va dirigido para esta
gente que viene acá pasar vacaciones y
qué pasa después sí claro que hay que
mencionar que este programa existe hace
muchísimo asaja va pero ubica más bien a
países del norte disfrazadamente no
todos los países del sur ni mes tras mes
pero participa chile email medio chile
méjico y no lo consiste exactamente eso
permitir dentro de las convenciones que
se firmaron entre los gobiernos de estos
países y canadá para intercambio de
jóvenes que están entre la edad de 10 ya
digamos 20 años hasta 35 años a poder
venir a visitar al país pero teniendo un
permiso de trabajo que le permita
vacacionar pero al mismo tiempo vivieron
una experiencia profesional en el país y
que permita justamente una primera
entrada a una ropa
probable una probable inmigración
permanente porque existen programas
van a acoger a justamente a este tipo de
especies específico exactamente antes de
continuar tenemos un mensaje mi colega
leona gimeno que generalmente es el que
está con nosotros aquí entre los dos
pero ahora en este momento está del otro
lado hay un mensaje de ramón sepúlveda
no sé de dónde nos escribe graba olvida
y nos dice gracias por este programa y
gracias por esa información que estamos
ofreciendo en este momento ahora
si me permites pablo hay una pregunta
que se hacen los inmigrantes cuando
llegan acá y dicen bueno yo tengo tal
profesión quiero trabajar como hacen
ustedes no sé quién quiere responder más
de una como hacen ustedes también para
ir a buscar a ese inmigrante que quiere
trabajar y ofrecerle algo cualquier que
quien quisiera
bueno pues precisamente foros como éste
permiten precisamente encontrar a estas
personas obviamente me imagino nosotros
en alpa y me imagino que los otros
centros
tenemos diferentes medios de difusión
para dar a conocer nuestros servicios de
búsqueda de empleo al patio en eso
hacemos eso difusión y lo primero bueno
encontramos a los les damos cita van y
tenemos un programa de acompañamiento al
empleo y no existe ustedes no se asocian
por ejemplo con empresas para ir a
buscar juntos sé que lo que nosotros
hacemos de la parte de fuera un 2020 es
venir con empresas de la región y
hacemos el reclutamiento de perfiles con
respecto a quién lo que puede contribuir
un organismo aquí en montreal por
ejemplo los perfiles de candidatos
nosotros venimos con la empresa eso lo
estamos haciendo regularmente y hay
muchas empresas que emplean aterrorizan
flows por ejemplo el email hemos venido
con las sondas son empresas de trabajo
son esos son trabajos a la base son
trabajos en industria ok pero tienen la
parte de administración y la parte
la fábrica son algunas son canadá eeuu
incluso entonces para los inmigrantes es
una buena manera de atraerlos ok
entonces una vez que están atraídos a
través del empleo a través de los
salarios incluso en regiones a veces es
un poquito más alto que en aquí en un
montreal hay empresas que empiezan a
pagar a la base y una líder allá 17
dólares 16 dólares 19 todo el horario
mínimo que a diferencia de montar
entonces para nosotros después viene la
contribución de presentar la biblia y
presentar cuál ha sido la edad de
presentar la presenta la ciudad perdón
representa cuáles son los precios de los
departamentos etcétera entonces siempre
con esta diferencia las regiones ganan
en ese sentido ganan población nosotros
de igual manera tenemos un programa de
pre empleo que en este momento pues vale
la pena que estoy ante el icono en que
consigue es ofrecer la oportunidad a un
grupo de jóvenes entre 15 y 30 años a
que participan a un programa de 16
semanas donde nosotros les pagamos como
un salario mínimo
y ellos participan de ocho semanas en
talleres en charlas en hacer sucede en
participar a una entrevistas y
verdaderamente ver en qué carrera ellos
quieren continuar sus estudios o en qué
sitio laboral ellos quieren entrar a
trabajar las próximas ocho semanas les
permitimos que hagan una pasantía en el
lugar donde a ellos les gustaría
trabajar en un futuro filia se están
preparando para esa integración tan
necesaria que es el iclei va ahora y
pasa a la integral exactamente para los
que estén interesados pueden dirigirse a
nuestro organismo en este momento
estamos en el período de reclutamiento y
comienza en septiembre pero las
inscripciones son un mes de julio es que
se pueden dirigir a carla y con gusto
pues ahí lo recibimos ahora sí ahí me
gustaría agregar hablando de
reclutamiento y aprovechando que hay
mucha gente que nos escucha al exterior
de canadá que ven internacional en una
parte de sus mandatos es apoyar a las
empresas de la región
pues para que vengan y se estable o son
los trabajadores temporales extranjeros
o esa otra categoría exactamente son
temporales pero no se trata de puestos
calificados no es el programa que existe
el de trabajadores temporales para el
industria agrícola es justamente las
empresas de la región de quebec que
trabajan con québec internacional y
participan a distintas misiones de
reclutamiento que llamamos en distintos
países del mundo estamos presentes en
francia en túnez y sobre todo en américa
latina con una misión de revertir países
de la américa latina es principalmente
recibimos candidaturas de mexico de
colombia y de brasil baja pero nuestra
nuestra iniciativa de reclutamiento en
línea que es tiene tiene lugar cada año
en el mes de septiembre y que publicamos
las ofertas de empleo a partir del 8 de
junio permite a la gente que esté en
méxico que está en brasil que está en
chile en argentina no importa el país
postular desde su casa desde su país de
origen a más de 60 ofertas de empleo
compuestos calificados en la región de
la ciudad de québec en hay muchos
postulantes
demasiados y demasiados no estamos
hablando de que hay una crisis aquí de
falta de mano de obra en todos los
sectores de la sociedad
yo como lo pudiera abordar es que
tenemos una gran diversidad de un gran
crecimiento en la región de quebec en
nuestras empresas están creciendo son
creativas son innovadoras y están
abiertas a recibir talentos del
internacional
al mismo tiempo ellas están innovando
también para automatizar sus procesos e
incluir nuevas tecnologías para la
producción por ejemplo pero aquí es
donde la inmigración y la aportación del
talento internacional juega un papel
fundamental el año pasado en nuestra
misión de reclutamiento en línea en
américa latina' recibimos más de 15.000
candidatura y no entonces y 15.000 más
de 15.000 candidaturas y de éstas se
seleccionaron 5 mil 800 personas que
pasaron en entrevista todo esto en línea
desde su país de origen de esto hablamos
de 100 personas que consiguieron un
empleo
eran reclutadas y que vendrán a quebec a
establecerse con un trabajo y con su
familia en los próximos meses entonces
nosotros invitamos a que la gente que
está en su país de origen que postulen a
las ofertas de empleo sobre el sitio web
que beck en la cabeza puntocom ahora si
me permite es pablo ustedes saben que
cuando un inmigrante llega aquí a quebec
pues tiene que hablar francés ese es una
exigencia central si uno quiere
integrarse a esta sociedad y además
participar laboralmente hablando pues
como hacen ustedes qué servicios ofrecen
para lo que se llama la francis acción
de los inmigrantes es que tienen
programas especiales no sé quién quiere
contestar bueno ensayando richelieu
tenemos cómo funciona un programa por
ejemplo está la educación para el
colegio educación para adultos que
ofrece servicios de francis acción a
tiempo pleno y a tiempo parcial y
tenemos también el servicio de francis
acción para las personas que trabajan y
que quieren mejorar sufran
en nuestro local aunque ofrecemos
servicios de francis acción en la tarde
después de la jornada laboral o también
se pueden en convenio con el ministerio
de inmigración hay un servicio de
francis acción directamente en las
empresas y adriana ustedes están se
asociaron con el gobierno de quebec el
organismo de ustedes está trabajando
conjuntamente es que hay alguna parte
que incluye por ejemplo servicios de
aprendizaje de enseñanza del francés que
tienen ustedes si claro que sí hay en
alpa ofrecemos los cursos de francés
acción que están vinculados a los jefes
del gobierno son los que ofrece el
gobierno entonces bueno tenemos
diferentes horarios las inscripciones
están sucediendo ahora porque vamos a
comenzar pronto en julio la nueva los
nuevos cursos de que es la estación de
verano porque va por cuatro estaciones
verano otoño e invierno primavera
ahorita estamos terminando primavera
simplemente tienen que ir al para
inscribirse llenar una ficha es el
procedimiento a seguir con su documento
de inmigración y es todo gratis todo
son gratuitos son cursos a tiempo
parcial y tenemos tres diferentes tipos
de horario mañana tarde y noche que no
sé si cápsula también creo que tiene
servicios de enseñanza del francés no
estoy serio transición en el organismo
no tenemos acuerdo lo que sí tenemos en
la asociación con el centro y piaggio
que es el centro de francés acción de
adultos a la cual nuestra clientela
hispana es referida a la escuela de
acuerdo tenemos acá un mensaje de qué
tipo oliver que felicita justamente a
cecilia por el trabajo de alpa gracias
no son intervenciones que vienen de las
personas que nos están escuchando en
este momento en directo desde facebook
live bueno la pregunta que yo lanzó para
todos ustedes
usted es bueno hay organismos aquí
presentes que están trabajando en
montreal otros en quebec otros en región
cuáles son los desafíos para organismos
como los de ustedes de trabajar ya sea
en las regiones o ya sea en montreal el
principal desafío que están enfrentando
para un principal desafío es justamente
combinar o hacer que correspondan las
necesidades de las empresas en materia
de empleo con el perfil de los nuevos
gigantes y los podemos decir de los
nuevos inmigrantes a quebec y sobre todo
de su integración que se puedan sentir
como en su casa cuando llegan a
instalarse en quebec y que se
establezcan de manera duradera muy bien
alguien más
yo diría nosotros trabajamos el proyecto
de la regionalización en colaboración
con el ministerio de la inmigración
somos financiados por el ministerio de
la inmigración y por amplia que ver los
servicios nuestros servicios son
gratuitos para las empresas y para los
individuos las familias
yo diría que uno de los desafíos más
importantes es que las personas que
están en montreal y quieren partir en
regiones estén listas a entrar en un
medio 100% francófono a conocer al 100%
la cultura quebequense a entrar como una
en una inmersión donde el vecino en el
supermercado van a estar hablando
francés yo lo veo mucho y es la mejor
escuela digo es la mejor escuela
entonces a veces digamos las familias
las personas tienen un poco de inquietud
de cómo se pasa en las regiones cierto
es que en región no hay la diversidad
cultural que uno encuentra en montreal
en el caso de sant joan' tenemos más o
menos unas 4000 personas inmigrantes que
vienen si 31 países diferentes pero para
el que quiera venir a montreal se toma
el auto y quiere venir hacia el
apartamento durante colombiano mexicano
argelino no importa está en monte
exactamente pero bueno el desafío sería
un poco es estar listo mentalmente en su
espíritu
su mente para enfrentarse y prepararse a
a recibir toda la información de la
cultura de la forma de pensar de las
personas que viven en región y no
hablamos de la temperatura ni del
infierno todo
yo quería que un desafío muy importante
a completar en el tiempo es también
cambiar seguir cambiando la mentalidad
en términos de contratación de personal
porque si bien es cierto ha cambiado ha
evolucionado en términos de competencias
ya cuando empiezan a ser puestos más de
un nivel de altos más altos hay algo que
tiene que hacer clic en la mentalidad de
los reclutadores de la general está de
acuerdo el desafío más grande que yo veo
es que sí hay bastante desempleo acá en
montreal porque hablamos siempre de
reclutar del extranjero más familias si
yo me veo confrontada a eso en el
organismo de que muchas familias están
en la búsqueda de empleo entonces porque
no le dan empleo a ellos es por eso la
motivación al aprendizaje del francés y
de veras a dar una educación a las
empresas de que como tú dices se quiten
pues esos los estereotipos de que una
persona de nuestra comunidad no pueda
pues ascender a un puesto de barro por
habilidad más responsabilidad y segundo
su formación académica 19 abrió no si yo
sería de acuerdo con lo que están
diciendo todos hay varios desafíos que
al para tiene bueno recibimos tres mil
inmigrantes por año aproximadamente son
3.000 desafíos pero nos gustan los
desafíos y eso yo quería
la sensibilización de la sociedad sería
un desafío la sensibilización de
propietarios porque hay muchos
inmigrantes que llegan no importa su
estatus migratorio y son es muy difícil
que consigan vivienda este es un gran
desafío también porque eso no sea porque
no tienen referencias no tienen historia
crediticia no tienen no trabajan todavía
que eso va ligado a otro desafío que es
la sensibilización de los empleadores
también entonces sí así es
y yo tendría una pregunta para nadie en
ese sentido usted es la oficina del
dibujante de abogados con los que
trabajan tienen pues si ustedes tienen
que resolver problemas de estudiantes de
trabajadores temporales de gente de
negocios los que buscan residencia
permanente
también apadrinamiento que ese es un
tema que a veces nos preguntan como
apadrinar a la familia entre todas estas
categorías que estamos nombrando de
inmigrantes cuales según nuevos el mayor
desafío de que el sector exactamente el
para mí y para mucha gente más bien que
vienen de afuera y que quieren viniera
trabajar en canadá el gran desafío es
como entender al procedimiento para
entrar no solamente yo aplico pues yo
vengo eso es toda una historia que creo
concibe que
internacional y ya lo entiende muy bien
que sí que se han recibido miles y miles
de demandas y oficinas de destinación
que nada en túnez marruecos y parís ha
recibido mil miles de miles y miles pero
no todo el mundo va a poder venir
con vómito a un poco como decía adquirir
de mitificar un poquito la situación
porque querer ir a trabajar
lograrlo legalmente y llenar los
procedimientos es otro mundo porque es
un procedimiento que digo que es muy
complicado que yo tiempo es que lleva
tiempo en las ofertas laborales están
sometidas absolutamente a exigencias del
mercado laboral que también que tiene
que controlar y verificar las
necesidades reales del mercado interno
porque tienen que proteger el mercado
local para no ser absorbido lo cual
lleva a que uno tiene que hacer una
selección a elección de lo que van bien
concreto que los empleadores canadienses
si quieren reclutar pero las leyes
todavía no están muy bien flexibles para
permitir una apertura
abierta así bueno yo quiero el fulano
trabajando el service canadá que es la
oficina que va a evaluar lo que se llama
el impacto de la oferta laboral sobre el
mercado local para ver si no va a crear
desempleados dentro es todo un mecanismo
técnico bastante complicado para alguien
que esté fuera del país e inclusive para
los empleadores que van muchas veces a
acudir a las oficinas de abogados que
están especializados en este tipo de
procedimiento y también hay derechos que
se pagan los empleadores para ofrecer
una oferta ofrecer un trabajo con
planeado entonces espero que haga
realizable plan realizable en el mar
derechos y explicar
motivar porque explicar decir cuáles son
los demás procedimientos que usted ha
realizado para buscar mano de obra local
que no la ha logrado para ir afuera y
demostrar la necesidad y pagar los
derechos etcétera desafortunadamente
desafortunadamente el tiempo pasa como
agua entre los dedos
nos quedan si veo bien en el crono seis
minutos quiero antes que todo
señalar a cada unos mensajes que nos han
llegado danny tapia dice saludos desde
méxico a sara tapia por su gran
desempeño dentro de quebec internacional
un fuerte abrazo de parte de toda la
familia que viene por su hijo se dice un
desafío es la discriminación que sufren
los latinos a nivel laboral son muchos
más discriminados por los que bq a que
por otras comunidades es la señal de
comentario de josué josué y nuevamente
danny tapias pues que saluda
un gran desempeño dice dentro de quebec
e internacional y bueno como les decía
el tiempo pasa rapidísimo nos quedan
escasos cinco minutos
yo quiero antes que se me olvide
agradecer a nuestros técnicos hoy pierde
long y ya que lebron lo hago antes de
que de que el tiempo nos arroyo y muy
rápidamente si tienen una última un
último mensaje que hacer pues amigos es
el momento y lo más breve posible
cecilia comunidad latina en montreal
esfuérzate por aprender perfectamente el
francés y el éxito está asegurado
lo que le puedo decir de la parte de
fórum en sant ya saben que los invitamos
a venir a la región es una región muy
muy enérgica muy muy productiva nosotros
atendemos de lunes a viernes estoy en
contacto por skype por las personas que
me quisieran escribir desde el
extranjero los podemos teledirigida
realmente a quienes le podrían darle una
buena respuesta y eso que las empresas
necesitan pies y manos para trabajar los
esperamos para invitar a todos los que
nos escuchan y nos ven a consultar el
sitio web www que ve que en la cabeza
puntocom a partir del 8 de junio más de
60 ofertas de empleo disponibles en la
región de quebec también yo de que ve
que la creación harían haría bueno
limpia todas las personas que estén en
búsqueda de empleo el requisito mínimo
tener un permiso trabajo vigente en
canadá tenemos muchas ofertas de empleo
tenemos contactos con más de 400
empresas conocemos las personas de
recursos humanos a veces el propietario
el jefe de equipo podemos contactarlos
nosotros no pedimos la carta de
presentación vamos a presentar las
candidaturas yo doy mi correo
electrónico maría mejía con jota
lan cree lea en ese punto sea adriana si
busca empleo si quiere estudiar francés
o cualquier otro servicio de inmigración
puede escribir a alpa a lp al para
número telefónico 51 42 55 39 00 y es
servicios gratuitos y en varios idiomas
nadie invitó a todos nuestros oyentes
hispanos americanos a contactarnos antes
de venir a canadá desde afuera para
informarse muy bien de cuándo cuáles son
los procedimientos que cumplir para
poder lograr su llegada a canadá a
trabajar ya vivir bueno yo tenía un
mensaje que me habían pasado aquí pero
no se ha concretado y es que el alcalde
de la ciudad de québec que se regirá
bono se encuentra aquí en el salón de la
inmigración me habían dicho que lo iban
a traer acá porque tenía un anuncio muy
importante que hacer con respecto a el
tema que nos interesa que es la
inmigración que al parecer hay
inversiones en perspectiva pero bueno
le agradecemos al público que está allá
del otro lado de la cámara y que está
aquí presa de anda no son nosotros en el
palacio de congresos en esta séptima
edición del salón de la inmigración y de
la integración de quebec
leonora muchísimas gracias pablo y
gracias a todas gracias a ustedes y les
recordamos que hay una versión audio de
este programa como ustedes saben esto
está saliendo en directo por facebook
youtube y en nuestro sitio internet r6
net punto sea pero también ponemos una
versión audio en nuestro sitio internet
a la que pueden consultar y en el que de
hecho se encuentra también se encuentra
también este vídeo que estamos grabando
aquí en en este salón y bueno eso fue
todo por este programa de este castor
cibernético canadá en las américas café
para hoy miércoles no mentiras jueves 31
de mayo
bueno generalmente este problema sale
los viernes pero bueno hoy estamos acá
jueves presentando les el programa eso
fue todo por hoy
muchísimas gracias chau gracias
escuchar
[Aplausos]